this next story is really interesting
because it combines politics with
procedure and with legality and people
have been wondering on our subreddit in
phone calls that I've received if Nancy
Pelosi wanted to could she wait to send
the articles of impeachment to the
Senate for a trial until a more fair
trial has been agreed to with Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell or
merely for political reasons like if
Nancy Pelosi says we'd be better off
starting this thing in June when Trump
will be debating the Democratic nominee
Oh much more much more promptly soon
after could she do that and Mitch
McConnell of course has said it's not
going to be a fair trial he said he will
openly coordinate the trial with Donald
Trump letting the accused run their own
trial or at least influence it that
Mitch McConnell is not an impartial
juror as required by the Constitution so
there's the question what if Nancy
Pelosi Waits and negotiates and that is
exactly what she now said is going to
happen Nancy Pelosi last night saying
after Donald Trump had been impeached
quote we have legislation approved by
the Rules Committee that will enable us
to decide how we will send over the
articles of impeachment we cannot name
impeachment managers until we see what
the process is on the Senate side this
may actually be a pretty slick way of
getting some concessions from
Republicans in the Senate or if not of
simply having the trial at a time that
would be more disadvantageous to Donald
Trump because remember Trump has already
talked about stretching the trial as
long as possible because he believes
that would be advantageous to him you
know as he sees it it may be true it may
not be the longer the delay before the
trial starts the longer that Trump is
just an impeached president not an
acquitted president that's interesting
and of course the longer that the delay
goes the more likely it is to start
overlapping not only with Democratic
primaries if it goes long enough it'll
start overlapping with general election
debates you could conceivably have
Donald Trump doing campaign spending
buying campaign ads at the same time
that there is an impeachment trial going
on which is almost
like free money for advertising from the
other side the fact that there would be
an impeachment trial going on I don't
think that the trial happening closer to
Election Day is good for Trump as a big
picture thing aside from his followers
who of course will be enraged by the
mere fact that the trial exists you know
the more casual voter the tens of
millions of people who vote but they
don't follow politics so closely if it's
getting close to Election Day and they
know the president is under impeachment
trial that is going to dissolve some
votes that would otherwise have gone to
Donald Trump
that is the leverage that Nancy Pelosi
now has with the idea of delaying when
she's going to send the articles of
impeachment over to the Senate now once
again we're speculating about what the
impact might be but we are once again an
unprecedented territory here at a
minimum this throws off Republicans and
Trump because the plan they had Mitch
McConnell's plan was to immediately do a
kangaroo court which this is what
they've been saying has already gone on
the real kangaroo court would be the
Senate trial Mitch McConnell wants maybe
drag it out
maybe not but get the headlines through
the media and then move on with claims
of vindication
now instead it's headlines of Trump is
impeached Trump is impeached and these
are going to go on for a while without
the benefit of the vindication
storylines that would almost certainly
come after an acquittal the narrative
has been taken from Republicans and is
now Trump has been impeached period and
that will stay the narrative until Nancy
Pelosi decides she's ready to send
impeachment articles to the Senate Trump
wants this to move on so that he can be
acquitted and gloat and now he's going
to have to sit and sit and tweet and sit
as an impeached president and now Trump
is tweeting that Nancy simply can't do
this saying quote this morning I got
impeached last night without one
Republican vote being cast with the
do-nothing Dems on their continuation of
the greatest witch hunt in American
history
now the do-nothing Dems want to do
nothing with the articles and not
deliver them to the Senate but its
Senate's call does an impeached
president have international credibility
among other world leaders I don't know
doesn't sound like it's too good
Trump what's that phrase that Don Jr
used about the Russian lawyer meeting
something like if it's what you say I
love it especially later in the summer I
think it applies doubly here
particularly if this thing even
conceivably stretches beyond spring and
at some point we will figure out what
the timing of it is but I think there
are many criticisms of Nancy Pelosi I do
think it was a mistake not to include
emoluments in the impeachment articles
but this is pretty slick and I think it
may actually work even if it only works
to send Trump again off the rails that
probably in and of itself is worthwhile
today's program brought to you in part
by Blink accom slash Pakman blinka
is a great service that I use all the
time what they do is they take thousands
of the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink Asst
I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS Jobs and there is a great new book of
BS Jobs by David Graeber
which I listened to on bling cos they're
constantly adding new books to the
platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
is calm slash Pakman if you're watching
on YouTube I'm putting a link in the
video description and after the free
trial if you like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
that's be Li NK is t.com /p a que mas